ah it's a beautiful [__] day to
be alive
what's happing you bad [__]
uncle Joey here Friday the 21st of
[__] September you're three months
away from Christmas and you're
scratching you had gone what the [__] is
going out with my world thank God it's
Friday Friday Friday slinging dick and
given our chopsticks you understand me
uncle Joey direct coming to you just to
let you know I got you my heart goes out
to Puerto Rico my heart goes out they
can cool whatever the couscous Islands
there's a [__] up out there Mexico you
know Florida everybody's trying to put
the pieces together the Koreans are
going off [__] the presents going off
it's [__] going down you understand
me the only thing that's keeping
[__] like us together is the
reefer of debt you follow me what Korean
missile what the [__] are you talking
about anyway
it's a beautiful day to be alive you're
awake you got your health
you got another [__] day to impose
your will on these [__] much walking
around
I love goose goose get the [__] out of
here I love [__] reefer
anyway it's a good week you're still
here you got the weekend coming up who's
better than you the podcasts are ready
for you I did podcast I went to jujitsu
I had meetings I wrote I've been busy
lately [__] so I just want you to
know I've been thinking about you
because where are you [__]
I got who God see understand me me and
the Christ killer a very thankful for
you [__] for always supporting
the podcast but Joey what's with the
chitter chatter what are you on the
table today we got some deep sleep you
understand you know what that means
right
and then we got a little [__] what's
this classic og perennial I'm playing as
usual with the best [__] weed
in the valley let's do a little bolt
together why do these balls like nothing
I had done that said it's all over the
lung power and sensational if I could
have this in terms of cardio forget
about it
[__] forget about it you could feel
the tingles in your [__] head you
understand me
listen man in today's world you don't
need nobody you got you [__]
that's what people on the stairway the
iPhone the I what about the I my big
date you follow me cuz that's what you
showing up with today my eye big dick
okay [__] the iPhone in the eye huh oh
my god I love my new iPad we'll listen
about the I [__] you ever have the I
[__] that's what you're strong
actually you're [__] got strap
between your [__] legs today you
ain't taking [__] from nobody understand
me you're writing down your goals you're
doing your [__] push-ups and you're
looking that [__] in the eye and
tell him listen I ain't doing it you
could suck my dick I was looking for a
job when I found this one you follow me
I took it's all about being your own
[__] man doing it your way like
[__] Sinatra and nobody like
[__] Sinatra buddy told the more the
suck is dick why because he covered the
spread
people like me nobody [__] likes me
but I don't give a [__] my job is to
cover this spread on a [__] daily for
myself and my family and for my [__]
friends you follow me
that's all I [__] worry about
everything else is background [__]
music I don't give a [__] about coffee I
don't give a [__] about the weekend
playing I don't give a [__] what's
important to me is that we sling dick
every day and nobody [__] with us you
follow me anyway I'm sorry I got a
little emotional from time to time
it's [__] reefer anyway it's the
weekend people were starting to go
[__] crazy you know me I don't give a
[__] I'm too old to give a [__] I don't
give a [__] whether it's Monday Sunday
or [__] Tuesday I wake up that
morning ready to sling dick tip top
Magoo
oh I'm gonna thank you again for helping
my niece out every time she sees one of
those things from the church it helps
her out so thank you very much I'm
flying in their [__] Wednesday to
spend the day with her then Thursday
night the party stop this party starts
in [__] Pittsburgh PA not since
Roberto [__] Clemente are you guys
gonna happen that much action next week
we're going [__] down next weekend
we'll light in that [__] town on fire
you better tell the [__] fire
department in Homestead to get the hoses
ready cuz we're [__] sparking you're
follow me anyway it's a beautiful day
man
yeah yeah you got your family but most
importantly you got yourself oh I can
let these [__] know who's
running things go out then let these
[__] know you went home last
night and made up your [__] mind that
you ain't taking it no more you follow
me we're not gonna take you
[__] that's what it's all about
my world everything else is what we
gonna do get together and drink coffee
and tell each other [__] story the
political forefront who gives a [__]
about the political forefront you
understand me
won it it's gonna press one button the
other it's gonna press the other button
and let's see what happens we're all
gonna be laying around scratching our
heads with [__] spots all over us but
you know what the most important thing
is today you're alive you got another
chance to [__] do your thing man so
get out there tell these [__]
to suck your dick and let him know that
uncle Joey sent you that you're leaving
the house today with the frame I thought
that you know what somebody's gonna
sniff my [__] nutsack today and
sometimes they don't
but at least you think that all day and
you walk around with a smile on your
face you follow me and at the end of the
day that's the most important thing your
mind [__] yourself and to going out
there and being the best version of you
now without further ado I got [__] to do
and people to see you know I love you
[__] with all my heart without
you I'd be a [__] sack of [__] well
I'm still a sack of [__]
but just part-time now I love you
[__] don't forget church.com
whatever the [__] it is go download it
Joey Diaz that net if you want dates but
the only date I'm concerned about right
now is Pittsburgh next weekend I'm gonna
go [__] off so if I was you get the
horse and buggy ready you know I'm
saying tell the [__] tell us those
people in Pennsylvania with the beards
and [__] whatever the [__] they are tell
those [__] to get a horse and
buggy ready I love you [__]
have a great weekend keep your eyes open
hug your family and don't forget uncle
Joey loves you I got you [__]
and always remember at the end of the
day they didn't get my Medela ping the
AIA booked a seat I did that wrong kind
of corn pilot Betty anything my my damn
[__] gone and if they ask you tell them
I sent you
have a good day uncle Joey loves you